All Right, ladies and
gentlemen, let's get started.
We are going to continue
our discussion of melody.
And last Thursday we were talking
about melody in terms of scales,
major scales, minor
scales, chromatic scales.
Then we went on to talk a little bit
about what it is in a melody that makes us
feel the way we do about
that particular melody,
the major and minor quality of them
in the fact that that quality shows up
rather early on in the scale.
The third step of the scale.
Then we talked about conjunct
melodies and disjunct melodies,
and we ended up talking
about Beethoven's Ode to Joy,
which he incorporated in the last
movement of his last symphony,
symphony number nine.
And we said that that had a particular
quality of phrase construction and a seat
and the consequent phrase struggle,
opening it up
and closing it back down. And I was
thinking over the weekend of all the,
all the pieces that operate that way
and the seating,
consequently,
then it goes all over the extension,
the way Beethoven with
all with an extension
antecedent.
Consequently, uh, I was thinking
of of a piece of Mozart,
Eh,
Mozart. Well let's listen here just a
little bit of what that really hears.
Okay.
Then Nick, go ahead. Sorry.
[inaudible] that's enough
dumb Patrick. Right. Okay. Don't Patrick.
All they did was take the theme with
the Macarena and the strip away all the
rhythmic stuff underneath and put an
18th century Alberti based with it and
Mozart would have used
and so on.
But the point here
is that even the mock arena is using
this antecedent and consequence for a
structure,
something as basic as that.
So it's sort of endemic to how
melodies are constructed. Uh,
now I was thinking and I always
liked to try to come up with a new,
however I'll be at lane brain
ideas for teaching this class.
Supposing I got a student up here, I mean,
melody, what makes a melody beautiful?
What makes a great melody?
Anybody know?
Well if you do let me know cause I
don't know and nobody really knows it.
It's sort of like the
definition of pornography.
You can know it when you see it or you
know it when you hear it. Um, so in,
in pursuit of this, I was
trying to think, well,
maybe I'll have a student come up and
try to craft a melody right here. Uh,
oh on the spot. And I suppose we could
play with that. But then I said, well,
it's probably not a good idea because a,
uh,
no student would really
want to do this and be,
it would probably take too long to
work through all the aspects of it.
So what I did, and this was about four
o'clock yesterday afternoon, I said, well,
all right Craig,
you think of a melody.
So I started thinking up
a melody and I can hope,
I hope I can remember how it went,
something like that. So what would you
give me as a grade for that melody?
Come on now. Uh, Daniel, what
do I get for that melody?
That was pretty good.
B minus C plus B. Well, we,
this is great invasive grade inflation.
So I'd been inflated up to a B,
but it was kind of,
see steam line is um,
it wasn't particularly inspire,
but in,
in crafting that it made me think of
all why do I do this at this particular
point? And not that well
there's certain parameters,
certain confines that we're operating
with. We've got to be in a scale,
certain kinds of phrases,
something ending like that in a piece
that's going to end here tells me that's
gotta be in the middle, that can't come
at the end. So there's a syntax here also,
we've talked about that before,
that musical phrases have to come in a
particular order for them to make sense.
So, um, instead of working with my lane
brain melody, let's work with a great one.
We're going to work with a melody by
Giacomo Puccini here and you can see his
name on the board up there and getting
a sense of the melody in question.
It's an Aria and we'll talk
about when Ari is later,
but he's an aria from his opera,
Johnny sqeaky.
Now that's not a well
known opera by Puccini.
Can anybody tell me the name of
a better known opera by Puccini.
Tosca. Yup. Madame Butterfly.
I haven't hit the most obvious one yet.
Libel in for example,
all rent was based on level and uh,
so he's written a lot of well known opera
as this happens to be a lesser known
opera,
but it has one sort of drop dead beautiful
melody in the thick oatmeal bomb beat
Bobby no car where a young lady is trying
to in effect constant money out of her
father. Um, and it's an odd thing.
This thing is so beautiful but trying to
separate her father for money is an odd
thought and it occurs rather early
on in the opera too and dramatically.
It's not of any particular significance.
It's just happens to be an absolutely
gorgeous melody that you've all heard
many, many times. One
day I was, and you'll,
you'll recognize it as
soon as I started to play.
One day I was playing this at home,
my then 13 year old son came in and said,
I know that,
that's beautiful.
That's my boy. He's going
to be a music lover. Yeah,
that's the background
music for grand theft auto.
What's, what's grand theft auto
or Chris? Um, well I found out,
but it shows you that this,
this particular Arya has legs.
It's kind of kind of everywhere. So let's
listen to a little bit of Puccini's.
Amil Bambi.
Barberino car.
Okay.
Hey,
okay, let's pause it right
there. Let's pause it.
Okay.
What's kind of neat about that
right at the outset there?
What's that?
Ooh,
why did you, again, to our spirit
soar at that particular point.
We've got a large leap there.
It's a leap of a,
of an often we wouldn't
expect you to recognize that,
but it's interesting to the fold that in,
because we were talking
about actives last time.
So we have this opening phrase
and it's about to be coupled.
We're going to continue now with the
next phrase that will complete the
antecedent friends. So we'll listen.
We'll just continue please. Linda
is there. So we're sitting
here. Can you sing the tonic?
Okay,
well that's where we want to know
that that's what you wanted to.
So we're in this step
right above the time.
So that's the end of the aniseed
and frames the opening phrase,
but we're not on the top.
Okay.
So now we're going to continue and you
can imagine we're going to hear some of
that same music,
but ultimately it's going to come back
to the tonic hadn't gone away with from
it. Okay. Little more please.
Starting again.
Is something interesting happened?
Yeah.
Oh, here's her tonic. We
should be back to our tonic.
But that's not exactly what happened.
MMM.
We went to the melody note,
but underneath he harmonized it with an
unexpected harmony. We expected to hear,
we got,
so we were deceived.
They're a little bit,
and musicians called
this a deceptive cadence,
a deceptive cage when the whole thing
has been set up to come back to the tonic
with the tonic chord underneath, we get
something other than the tonic chord.
So in music we have two kinds of
really a broad categories of cadence.
We had this kind of thing called,
or where we come back
to the expected tonic.
We call those authentic keens.
We also have another class of,
as mentioned to set deceptive
cadences where we do things such as
we're expecting to go,
we go or we go even more bizarre,
something like that. You keep the
same tonic note in the melody,
but you change the harmony underneath,
so that's what Puccini has done here.
Instead of going there,
there,
here is a silly analogy.
One time I was flying into the city of
Minneapolis planes and fasten your seat
belts are but Trey's up,
et Cetera, except cetera.
Acceptor were coming debt right in there
where you can see the the tarmac there
and suddenly the plane was in her womb,
doesn't land,
does a barrel roll most off to the
right circles all the way around.
Announces there was some piece of
equipment on the landing strip and he was
doing a flyover in music.
You have to do the kind of thing.
If a composer has set this up so that
you're expecting to go and you don't,
you go here. We can't end that
way. We just can't end that way.
Do we need our daily supply of tonic?
So what we going to do as a musical,
fly over.
He's going to fly all around this thing
again and then come back in and this
time land on the tonic.
So let's listen to the fly over
eh,
but it's so lovely he can't stop.
So you're going to give you
a little reminiscence of
the beginning. Here's your,
so just a little reminiscent at the
beginning but again coming back in this 10
of course anyone at Tata,
so that's the structure of an Aria by
Puccini and it is highly structured.
It is highly structured.
Now I want to talk about another Aria
that's structured in a different way and
that's by Ricard Wagner.
But before we do that,
we need to talk about one other process
in music and that has to do with
something called melodic sequence.
And oddly students over the years have
had difficulty understanding and hearing
melodic sequence.
But it's a pretty simple idea.
Melodic sequence is simply the repetition
of a musical motive at a successively
higher or lower degree of the scale.
So I could take a take a motive. Anybody
want to sing a motor for me here, Daniel,
you want to sing a motive?
Gimme for notes.
Yeah.
Okay.
So we've set up a
descending melodic sequence.
Now supposing we did this
and
so forth,
that's obviously an snd melodic sequence.
So that's what's involved
here in generally speaking,
going down introduces relaxation,
going up, perhaps tension.
Um, all right, so that's a little
bit of a set up with regard to that.
So now we're going to work through this.
We'll call it an Aria for the moment
of a Wagner in which rather than a
structured units,
he's going to continually evolve new music
but using a motive that he presses up
continually through melodic sequence.
So it's a slightly different
process of melodic structure here.
Ricard Bogner and not,
um, a very nice man.
Not a very nice man. Did
it, needless to say it. Um,
but he was a spectacular composure and
wrote many great things. And one of them,
arguably the best that he wrote
is his opera, Tristan, Tristan.
And it's older, uh, written in 1865.
As you can see on the board here and we
should know about it because we here at
Yale own the piano on
which Wagner wrote Tristan,
it was at least involved
in part of Tristan.
Next time you are walking
past due over there,
you know the health center at 17,
he'll house happening.
There's a building there
rather foreboding looking.
Building inside is a wonderful
collection of keyboard instruments.
So go in there sometimes and
look at the Bechstein piano.
This German Piano Bechstein
it Wagner worked used when,
when working on on Trista.
So we have the um,
uh, the opera and we're going to
start here with a little bit of the,
of the plot. It's a story of
this English night, Tristan.
And this Irish princess is older and it's
Trish Danze job to go over to Ireland
and sort of pick her up and deliver
back to Cornwall where she's supposed to
marry a king mark. But
on the old route, uh,
they inadvertently consume a love potion.
So she is passionately in
love with him and he with her.
So we're going to listen to a little
bit of the overture here. Now.
Wagner actually called it a prelude.
That doesn't matter. Opening,
opening music here to um,
to Tristan.
And I have two questions
for you as we listen.
Hear what instruments are plain and what
musical process is Wagner using it at
this point. Okay, Linda.
Okay.
Stop it there. So what instruments were
playing here and that little dialog,
the dialog between
families of instruments,
strings and woodwinds. Okay.
Alternating back and forth.
The strings were at the lower,
then the woodwinds.
Good answer.
Then it
okay.
And so on. So what melodic
process were they using? Their
sequence sequence.
All right.
And then it sort of chugged
along until we got it.
What's this?
We talked about this before
in regard to Ricard Strauss
that sound
resolving to concert.
So it uses the sequence to work
up to a climax, hits a dissonance,
resulted into concert.
Let's listen to him a little bit further
along here in the prelude. Linda,
if you could move it up to seven 10
[inaudible] is way up here to see what
level gets higher and higher in the
violin.
And you heard the trumpets coming in.
Yeah.
With that chromatic figure, almost
kind of like a sneak rising through it.
So it's not only the
rising melodic sequence,
this is highly chromatic music and
that that also produces tension.
How do you make love in music?
Well,
we've got rising dynamic volume.
We've gotten rising sequence.
It works up to a climax where there
is dissonance and then release.
So if I'm using rather suggestive
language here, it's done intentionally.
Uh, this is the St Mary Poppins where the
sound of music or Snow White and seven
dwarves. This is the passionate
story of Tristan and Isolde, lust,
desire, carnal knowledge
that, that sort of thing.
And how does Wagner give you the sentence?
How does he communicate this? Well,
this idea of continually rising sequence
that then hits this climax with a
dissident, almost painful this and
it's, and then the resolution, uh,
musically to duplicating in an odd way,
life's processes, the climax of the opera,
the real climax.
However,
really doesn't come until about
three hours into it at the end.
Now we have Tristan
dying of a mortal wound,
uh, is older, is cradling him in her arms,
and she seems an Aria,
a, we'll call it an Aria.
Wagner gave it a different name,
the Lebus tote.
She's singing about her vision
of their life in the hereafter,
in the world beyond in
the celestial realm. Uh,
and so it's called a love
death. The Lebus tote here. Um,
and it's typical I suppose of the
conventions of the romantic period, right?
This is a 19th century.
This is Romance Tristan and adults.
So we're going to pick this up
about halfway through the, uh, uh,
Lebus toad of, of the
Zolder. Uh, and once again,
we will hear these little snippets,
these motives.
Okay. I don't have absolute pitch. When
you're really annoyed with things in life,
you can sometimes at least make some fun,
enjoy it somehow by trying to figure
out what key it's in. Okay. So that was,
that was a pipe in f we were listening
to it rather unreserved pipe in ethics.
Okay.
So let's go back to the mid point of
the liebers toe here and we're going to
hear these little snippets.
This is not NSC and the consequent,
this is a motive being pushed higher
and higher each time to a climax.
Here we go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Oh, is it? There it is. It's
glorious. It's Gloria, Sam.
And isn't it nice to have our audio
system working properly? Again,
this is really the first day that
has worked properly. Uh, so it's, it,
it sounds wonderful.
It's glorious.
It's a glorious climax that Wagner has
been working for for three hours here.
And we've got that we've arrived at and
now he's going to turn everything around.
The entire sentiment is going to change
and I think we should be able to,
to enumerate here maybe as many as four
different ways in which Wagner does to
earn our emotions 180
degrees at this point.
So we're going to go back and we're
going to listen to the climax again,
and then we're going to listen to how
the music changed. And I want you to,
as you sit there to think about
what's he doing here? What,
what you're the composer,
what would,
how do you make something go from a,
a sort of cradle in your
arms to vision of, of,
of the world beyond. So think
about dynamics, think about Tiempo,
think about these sequences, consonance
and dissonance, et Cetera, et Cetera,
et cetera. Okay, here we go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hmm. Well I hope you liked
that gorgeous stuff. Uh,
so get me started here. Get me started.
What did you hear there? How did he
sort of slow down entire training?
Yeah. Okay. The whole thing got
softer. So we're going to take the,
the basics first and that would
be sort of number one on my list.
The whole thing got softer.
What else happened?
Okay. Not only soft, although the
voice ended up rather high water.
The last salads we've heard
also to ended low and we've talked
about high and low intention,
that sort of thing before softer,
maybe lower generally in terms of the
test that to test the Torah or the range.
What else? Yeah, Christina. Yeah,
the tempo got slower. Well, yeah,
there were some points that the tempo
got slower and we'll talk about that in
just a minute if we hit
on anything else here. Um,
anything else? Instruments, uh,
well they weren't playing with loud.
They weren't quite as obvious.
I'm not sure that they
were fewer instruments.
My guess is if I were
to look at that school,
that would be huge and everybody
would still be playing. It's just,
it sounded fewer because they
were playing more quietly.
What about, um, the Roger,
sorry.
Yeah,
he used to, he used the distance.
For example, we had that,
that sneak ideas like
snake in the garden of Eden
was riding around there,
but then
he took it up to or degrees and
folded it in the, to a concert.
So it was all very consonant at the end.
What about the sequence
rising? Rising, rising. But here
at the end it started. Yeah,
it's just repeating the same pictures
over and over and over again.
So he took that out of the equation too.
Each are backed out.
This idea of the sequence, it's
static at this point. We have Stacy's,
we have a rival stability.
What were,
what was the one thing we
haven't mentioned, uh, in
terms of the tonality here?
They're at the end. What is
that last step? Very strongly.
The,
the tonic.
That's the way it was.
One of the things was kind of cool here.
I'm trying to think of the exact,
that kind of sound.
Supposing I went,
does this have any resonance to you?
Uh,
where are you?
If you hear that sound?
Yeah.
Maybe he'll commencement where we sing
hymns or in a church or something like
that.
What we would call that.
Aw.
What does that bring to the, it sort
of brings a divine benediction here.
Now is the 19th century.
Like there's more painful minor,
but if you feel you have a sense here
at the end that they're living a blessed
that existence in heaven,
it may because Wagner has folded in
sort of subliminally you're below the
surface, this, um, uh,
cadence that we've have deceptive cadences
and we have another kind of cadence
here called an Amen cadence, um, that, uh,
brings an additional resident in
addition to symbolism to the conclusion.
So it's a wonderful piece of
music. Um, and uh, maybe we,
we, I think we have time.
Let's listen to just the last
few seconds of that again,
because it's sort of recaps some
of the points we've been making
back it up even a couple
of seconds before that.
Yeah,
that's good.
Here's the snake going away.
Here's the consonant.
Okay. So that's the leavers tote of
Ricard boggling questions about that.
Thoughts about that, comments
about that. All right, if not,
let's go on to talk about Mozart.
A little bit more about Mozart.
When here another Aria, uh, by Mozart.
And this one does something a
little bit different than, well,
it's a kind of combination of
what we've just studied here.
We've got a highly
structured Aria by Mozart,
yet at the same time we're going to see
an example of rising melodic sequence in
it. And we have a guest artist today,
Lauren Liberal. So Lauren, come on up.
Some of you know,
Lara,
she's in Davenport College and I've
known her for years now because she is a
music major and I've seen you're seeing
in lots of different productions of the
school of Music's Orpheus in the
underworld a year or so ago. Um,
so Laura and I know that you've sung
with the Los Angeles opera and I remember
that you're saying with
David Stern in Brussels,
was it Brussels or Paris
or both? Oh, oh yeah,
she probably the shadow lay
in Paris. Yeah. Yeah. It's
a shadow. A theater there.
The big metro changing. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
so she used a very experienced singer
and a very, very good singer. So, but uh,
tell us, uh, Lauren, what do you want
to do with this? Here you are at Yale.
You could do,
you could become an opera singer or you
hit a good go to law school and worked
for Skadden, arps in New York or Los
Angeles or whatever you want to do. What?
Well,
what are you going to do with all this?
Um, I would like to pursue a
career in opera last school,
not the road from me, although I do
like to argue. I'm sorry parents.
So you're going to have the goal.
So this year that if you're a senior,
are you going to take a year off in an
applied directly to a graduate schools in
voice? And where are you
going to apply if you to do,
actually I'm going to go back to
work with David Stern, um, oh,
in Paris for a year and a young
artist program that they have there.
You're in that already are.
Yeah, he um, kindly has asked me.
David stern was a Yale undergraduate.
He is the son. He was the nicest boy.
The son of whom?
Of whom stern does that ring a bell?
I used to extern to the world famous,
the Great British violinist of
the 20th century. So David was in,
was an undergraduate here,
graduated probably 15 or so years ago.
Went on to a career in music
as a conductor, mostly in
Europe, mostly in Europe.
I think. He told me that he
went to ta for this class.
He like,
he would come in from time to time
and we would do things in here as an
undergraduate. He was not at
the haven. Well if there's any,
was conductor the YSL for a
couple of years too. Yeah. Um,
so he would come in from time to time
when we would do different things. So, um,
Laura's have as mentioned,
a very expensive experiencing are,
and we're gonna do a little art ra here
out of Mozart's figure robbers opera,
the marriage of Figaro 1786 called
void case a paytech. So Lauren,
can you tell us something about this,
that this Aria, who's singing it?
This Aria is sung by kid
Rubino who is a young boy.
Actually though I'm clearly not a boy
wearing pants for the purpose. Um,
it's called a trouser
role for that reason. Um,
sung by a woman in the Sabra.
Um,
why did they do that? What?
[inaudible] weird opera.
People like transvestites
or something like this.
There are other roles like this is just
kind of a convention and in opera kind
of a convention.
Yeah, he's a young boy. Um, so
maybe they got the higher voice.
Yeah, that's right. He's an adolescent
14. And what's he experiencing
first? Love, basically our
first lust. Um, he's not true.
He's not sure. So, uh, he's
singing to the Countess, uh,
with whom he is in love and
with a little help from, um,
Susanna, Susanna. Yeah. Yeah.
So he's not,
he thinks he's in love with the counters,
but maybe it Susan or maybe it's Barbara
arena or maybe it's a broomstick over
there. It's hard to know exactly what
he's in love with it. Age At age 14.
Um,
and that's the confusion here.
So there's a certain palpitation from
time to time in the singing. It's,
it's intentional here in a certain
sense of being flustered. Yeah. Almost.
You're agitated, you're flustered, you're
uncertain what all these things are. Um,
we're going to have Lauren seeing
all of this for us. Um, eh,
but in order to have this be something
other than just a performance,
I'd like to work with through
different pedagogical issues here.
So let's talk about
that just for a second.
Now at the outset of this,
and you guys have your sheets out there,
there was a sheet on this music stand
back there. Uh, you've got a sheet.
So take a look at that
and uh,
we'll see.
What do you see Marcus?
Right down here in the front row. What
do you see on your sheet by way of music?
It's broken up into
two different parts.
Okay.
Three.
And they're labeled
antecedent and consequence.
So Mozart's starts out here with the
antecedent consequence phrase structure.
That was the antecedent.
Here it comes.
So antecedent consequence.
Then interestingly enough,
when the voice comes in, what does
he do? What did, what did he do?
Then you have to sing.
You just don't duplicate what I did.
He actually expands the face
structure, I guess. Yeah,
by adding more material right
in the middle, you know,
too. So we had an a and B,
but he, his mind is such, I
mean, I'd never be able to
figure that out. And he said,
well,
Hey,
I can open this whole thing up and put
in some additional lovely music and then
close it back down with my consequent
phrase struck. Uh, so we have that.
Let's, let's listen to how that plays
out. So we'll just start with, uh,
with where you come in.
Lonely with Voi. Okay.
Hmm.
Rolling.
Okay. And then we go on with a series
of phrases. And as you listen to this,
you might count the number of bars and
phrases here, but generally speaking,
they're all four bars in length.
Mozart is one of the guys who sort of
puts this whole idea of structure with
melody on the Mat structure.
Symmetry are very important
in his compositions.
And as we proceed here,
the text gets more and more interesting.
We start talking about,
uh, feelings at line five.
They are sent home. Do not fat though,
I feel. How would you train? Well,
I guess we have it.
Great. Thank you. I feel
as though in Italian. Yeah.
Emotion.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and then sometimes he'd really happy and
then sometimes he's sort of despairing.
And what's kind of cool it when we
get over to this sparing idea here.
Yeah,
here we go again.
Then it's going to be burning like
a flame and then freezing to death.
So we get these
weird harmony out here cause
he's freezing and thawing.
So let's hear just a little bit
maybe with, from there at center
dot.
Okay.
No.
Hello.
Okay, now we're going to go onto a little
bit later. Lovely, lovely. Love it.
And we're going to go into a little bit
later if you can follow on your text too.
So speed of a Jmo sends oval
there of how B to a tray,
most sensors up there and so on.
What does Mozart Joe here
in terms of structure,
a sequence. Um, I think uh,
he repeats the same series of notes,
um,
progressively higher sort of to
illustrate Carol Bruno's rising, uh,
an angst slash.
Emotion.
Good. So, um, so you pick it up your beef
lot there and I'll try to catch up. Yeah,
it's the spirit.
Hey
Mom.
So notice there, uh, how as we come
to the end of that, we work up there.
We have the rises up through the melodic
sequence, rising melodic sequence.
We get Lauren hits that high note
up there and then comes off of it.
That's the climax, the peak of
the whole Aria. And then the base.
What's the base doing?
It's sort of
sneaking back down to the tonic. Okay. So,
and when we get back to the tonic, yes.
Comes in. We're going to pick
it up from there. And um,
Lauren, if you could, when we get,
we're going to sink through that.
We'll get over there to bog d.
Dot.
Just hold on core and we'll ask
them a question. What happened here?
What do we have here when we see
if you can hold on that quarter.
Some from the void?
Yeah.
Oh,
hello.
Hello.
Oh
Nice. Nice. So what did Mozart do there?
What was that perceptive kid
had a deceptive cadence. Good.
And Marcus scores big today.
So we're sitting here on,
on this,
oh,
we want it to go,
but instead it goes,
and then we have our fly over.
Okay.
And that's the way it is. So you come
back to the tunnel. Okay. We've arrived.
We've landed.
All right.
I think we have time to do the whole
thing now from beginning to end,
and we'll get our pages and order.
And
so Lauren labelle singing void case of
payday from Mozart's marriage of Figaro.
Ooh.
How's that been?
Maybe.
Hello?
Oh Wow.
Hello.
Lovely, lovely, lovely.
Aren't we fortunate to have
such talented students here?
Yeah. Okay, well thank you all very much.
We'll play a little more Puccini on your
way out, and I hope you enjoy this day.
As beautiful as all this music has been.